اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه الساعه الجديده
والتي نخصص معظمها لتطورات الاحداث في
السودان وروسيا والبدايه بالعناوين
الجيش السوداني يسيطر على منطقه كوبر بعد
معارك عنيفه في الخرطوم بحري صباح اليوم
سفير الاتحاد الاوروبي في القاهره يكشف
الى العربي عن قلق اوروبا من عواقب الحرب
في السودان
وفي اخبارنا ايضا
يتهم واشنطن بالوقوف وراء هجوم المسيرات
والبيت الابيض يؤكد ان مزاعم موسكو كاذبه
تحقيق الاسرائيلي يكشف خللا في منظومه
القبه الحديديه خلال التصعيد الاخير بغزه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا البدايه من ميناء جده
الاسلامي الذي يشهد وصول سفينه امريكيه
عسكريه قادمه من السودان ومعنى مراسل
العربيه عن السفيان اهلا بك هاني وماذا
لديك معلومات حول هذه السفينه
نعم اهلا بك واهلا من المشاهدين قناه
العربيه مره اخرى اذا من امام السفينه
الحربيه الامريكيه التي وصلت للتو الى
ميناء جده الاسلامي وتحمل على متنها 200 و
222 راكبا من جنسيات متعدده قادمه من
بورسودان هذه السفينه تعتبر السفينه
الثانيه للامريكيه
الحربيه وهي من ضمن عمليات الاجلاء التي
تنفذها فرقاطات وسفن وتجاريه وعسكريه
اجنبيه اليوم نتحدث عن عمليات الاجراء
التي نفذتها الفرقادات العسكريه الاجنبيه
او كذلك السفن التجاريه الاجنبيه هي
تتجاوز الخمسه عشر سفينه طبعا السفينه
العسكريه الامريكيه هي دخلت في مؤخرا ضمنا
عمليات الاجلاء لعل سبقتها الفرقاطه
الهنديه وكذلك الصينيه وكذلك السفن
الفرنسيه او سفينه واحده التي قامت باجلاء
بعثه الامم المتحده وكذلك الفرقاطه
الهنديه وايضا سفن تجاريه من دول متعدده
ولكن السفن العسكريه الامريكيه هي كانت
اخر السفن التي دخلت في ضمن عمليات
الاجلاء وتحديدا التي كانت
مغادره من ميناء بورت سودان الى وجهتها من
جده الاسلامي وهذه هي السفينه الثانيه
فقبل يومين كانت تحمل
305 اشخاص من سته عشره جنسيه والسفاره
الامريكيه لم تفصح عن عدد الجنسيات التي
تحملها هذه السفينه ما نشاهده هم وجود فقط
جنود على متن وظهر هذه السفينه بعضهم يحمل
السلاح وبعضهم ايضا ينتظر نزول الرعايه
وفي الطابق السفلي من السفينه ايضا نشاهد
عدد من الطاقم الفني الذي هو بانتظار
الاذن الاخير
الرام وهو الرام المتصل بين السفينه وكذلك
الذي سوف يكون بين السفينه ورصيف من جده
الاسلامي عموما نحن ما زلنا في اطار اخذ
او اذن الاخير من قبل الامن السعودي حتى
يسمح بنزول هؤلاء الرايه ولكن هناك
اجراءات ايضا داخل السفينه في حال توقفها
في حاله ايضا يتم التاكد من عدم خلل امنيه
او كذلك فنيد للسفينه قبل نزول هذا الرام
او هذا الجسر طبعا ايضا لا ننسى اذا لم
تفصح ايضا السفاره الامريكيه ما اذا كان
على متن هذه السفينه حالات طارئه او حالات
صحيه او كذلك اصابات مثلما كان في السفينه
الاولى فكانت هناك ثلاث اصابات ولكن حتى
الان لم يتبين لنا ما اذا كانت هذه
السفينه تحمل مصابين او ايضا مرضى او ايضا
ركاب لديهم حاله صحيه طارئه ولو وجد هذا
الامر فان هناك تواجد للاسعاف الخاص بمناء
جده الاسلامي وايضا هناك
الطاقم الطبي يتواجدون على الرصيف الخاص
والذي نقف فيه في ميناء جده الاسلامي
المرحله التي سوف تلي نزول هؤلاء الركاب
سوف يتجهون مباشره الى الحافلات ونشاهد
ايضا هنا حافلتين والاخريات في الخارج وهي
من ضمن التجهيزات التي وفرتها الخارجيه
السعوديه والتي سوف تقل هؤلاء الرعايه
وعددهم 222 من جنسيات مختلفه الى مقر
اقامتهم حتى يتم انهاء اجراءاتهم والتنسيق
مع قنصلياتهم وسفراتهم لمغادرتهم جده الى
بلدانهم نعم طيب هاني شكرا على هذه
المعلومات وسنبقى في متابعه معك والعود
اليك في حال نزول هؤلاء الرعايه من
السفينه لمتابعه اوضاعهم شكرا لك هاني
الصفيه مراسل العربيه بميناء جد الاسلامي
مشاهدينا ميدانيا ومع ثمار المواجهات بين
الجيش والدعم السريع منذ الصباح والتي
وصفت بالاعنف منذ بدء الصراع افاد مراس
العربيه بان الجيش سيطر على منطقه كوبر
وسلاح الاشاره في الخرطوم بحري فيما تقوم
قوات الجيش بتمشيط منطقه كوبر بعد السيطره
عليها هذا واظهرت الصور استهدافا
الجمهوري والقياده العامه بالخرطوم في هذه
الاثناء لا تزال الاوضاع الانسانيه الطبيه
في تفاقم مستمر فبينما اعلنت وزاره الصحه
ان 70% من المستشفيات باتت خارج الخدمه
لجا سودانيون للفرار من القتال الدائري
وسط مخاوف من ارتفاع موجه النزوح لارقام
قياسيه
[موسيقى]
في الاثناء مشاهدينا افاد مراسل العربيه
باندلاع معارك عنيفه في الخرطوم حيث دوت
الانفجارات منذ الصباح في محيط القصير
الجمهوري والقياده العامه للجيش مراسل
العربي اكد ان الخرطوم تشهد اشتباكات هي
الاعنف منذ بدء الصراع هذا وتشهد العاصمه
تحليقا للطيران الحربي الجيش بشكل مكثف
اما في ام درمان فتشهد المدينه اطلاقا
كثيفا للقضاء في المدفعيه بين الجانبين
لن تتوقف الاتهامات المتبادله بخلق الهدنه
بين الجيش والدعم السريع وفي اخرها اتهم
بيان الدعم السريع قوات الجيش بشن قصف
عشوائي على عدد من مواقع تمركز قوتها وبعض
الاحياء السكنيه رغم الهدنه الجديده التي
بدا سريانها اليوم بيان الدعم السريع اكد
ان القصف الذي شنه الجيش بالمدافع
والطائرات يشكل تجاوز للاعراف والقوانين
الدوريه في المقابل اكد الجيش ان قوات
الدعم السريع حاولت الهجوم على قياده
منطقه بحر العسكريه واضاف الجيش السوداني
ان قواته دمرت عددا من العربات القتاليه
التابعه للدعم السريع واستلمت 5 عربات تم
تركها في ميدان المعركه
مشاهدينا بالخرطوم معنا الان مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك السالم وهل
مازات الاشتباكات مستمره في الخرطوم
نعم احمد ما زالت مستمره حتى الان
الاشتباكات في مدينه الخرطوم وما زلنا نرى
اعمده الدخان من مناطق مختلفه من العاصمه
الخرطوم في هذه اللحظات تتجدد الاشتباكات
مع عزيزي الطائرات ونستمع ايضا لاصوات
لدانات ربما تم استخدامها ومضادات
للطائرات كذلك تستخدمها قوات الدعم السريع
في مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه الخرطوم نرى
اعمده الدخان في مناطق متفرقه هل يعمده
الدخان التي نراها الان عبر الشاشه يمكن
المصور ان يزيح الكاميرا نحوها هذه
المنطقه هي منطقه كافوري والتي ايضا تجدد
فيها الاشتباك في هذه اللحظات ونرى اعمده
الدخان من هنا يمكن ان ترى بالعين في اعلى
امتداد كافوري وكوبر والمنطقه الصناعيه
هذه المناطق كلها منها اعمده دخان
تتصاعد كل فتره تتجدد اعمده الدخان من
منطقه لاخرى في هذه المنطقه وهي منطقه
بحري في منطقه كوبر وبالقرب كذلك من
المنطقه الصناعيه الى كافوري وكلها محاده
لبعضها البعض الان نرى منها اعمده الدخان
الان احمد نسمع عزيزي الطائرات تحلق في
سماء الخرطوم ونستمع الى اصوات مضادات
الطائرات بمحيط مطار الخرطوم ومحيط
القياده العامه للجيش في هذه الاثناء من
المعلومات الوارده ايضا سالم الجيش سيطر
او احكم سيطرته على كوبر والسلاح الاشاره
المتاكدات
في بحر بالتاكيد
نعم وردت لنا التاكيدات نعم بانه تمت
السيطره على هذه المناطق وانه تم دحر قوات
الدعم السريع من هذه المنطقه
لتتراجع الى المنطقه الصناعيه
وفي محيط المنطقه الصناعيه وكذلك في
كافوري لان كافوري ايضا يوجد بها معسكر
معسكرات قوات الدعم السريع ومعسكر كان
يتبع لهيئه العمليات سابقا ما زالت قوات
الدعم السريع تتمركز في هذه النقطه ربما
يتم او يقوم الجيش السوداني بعمليات تمشيط
وهذا ما يمكن ان يفسر من تجدد هذه
الاشتباكات وكذلك اعمده الدخان وسماع
الاصوات في مدينه بحري التي شهدت حراكا
عنيفا في الساعتين الماضيتين هل هناك
امدادات او تعزيزات عسكريه تصل بشكل منظم
الى قوات الدعم السريع ام ان الجيش قد
احكم سيطرته على المداخل والمخارج
وبالتالي
منع وصول هذه التعزيزات الى مناطق تمركزات
قوات الدعم
نعم ظل الجيش السوداني يتحدث على انه
دائما يتحرر كل ما ياتي من قوات المتمردين
لدعمهم وانه يقوم بدحلها قبل ان تصل الى
الخرطوم ظل الجيش السوداني
يردد هذا الامر وفي اكثر من بيان لكن احمد
دعنا يقدر نتحدث عن موضوع الوضع الانساني
الذي نادى الجيش السوداني بان قوات الدعم
السريع هي سبب في هذا الامر لعل ابرز هذه
الامور موضوع المستشفيات التي تثار بين
الفينه والاخرى اخرها مستشفى ام درمان
للولاده والذي اصدر بيانا تحدث فيه على ان
قوات الدعم السريع دخلت الى هذا المستشفى
واخذت منه اموالا تضاف الى ذلك ايضا
المستشفيات الاخرى مثل المستشفى حاجه
الصافي
والمستشفيات التي تحدث عنها الجيش
السوداني من قبل مثل مستشفى شرق النيل
ومستشفى في مستشفى الولاده في ام درمان
ومستشفى حاج الصافي في مدينه بحري مستشفى
البراحه ذلك هذه المستشفيات كلها ظل الجيش
السوداني يتحدث على ان قوات الدعم السريع
تدخل الى هذه المستشفيات وتخرج المرضى ومن
ثم تسيطر على هذه المستشفيات هذا يدعو الى
كارثه واذا تحدثنا عن مستشفى الولاده في
ام درمان احمد تعلم جيدا انه من اكبر
مستشفيات الولاده في العاصمه الخرطوم
واسمه مستشفى الديات بين قوسين هنا في
السودان كما هو معلوم مستشفى سعته كبيره
جدا وهو من اهم المستشفيات في مدينه ام
درمان ربما هذا الامر اذا استمر بهذه
الطريقه يعني يصل بولايه الخرطوم الى
كارثه صحيه بالنسبه لولايه هل هناك بدائل
بالنسبه لسكان ولايه الخرطوم يعني الجؤون
الى مستشفيات في ولايه اخرى او مستشفيات
اخرى
ولكنها ليست حكوميه او اساسيه
نعم احمد كانت وزاره الصحه وكذلك مجموعه
من الناشطين في الموضوع الصحي تحدثوا على
انه يجب ان تفعل الولايات القريبه من
ولايه الخرطوم تفعل فيها مستشفيات يتم
فيها نقل المرضى الى هناك لكن تعلم احمد
ايضا ان وعوره الخروج من الاحياء نفسها
كذلك صعوبه التنقل الاوضاع الاخرى
المصاحبه والفاتوره الباهظه لهذه الحرب
تجعل حتى الخروج الى الولايات له تكلفه
كذلك حتى ان هناك يعني المناشدات في وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي وهي تتحدث عن الاسعافات
التي تنقل المرضى الى هذه المستشفيات خارج
الولايه وهذا هو الحل البديل الوحيد
بالنسبه للمرضى الذين يبحثون عن حل
اشكالاتهم خاصه الحالات الطارئه مثل حالات
الولاده التي لا تحتمل التاخير وكذلك
حالات غسيل الكلى وكذلك مساله العمليات
الذين قررت لهم عمليات مهمه ايضا كل هذه
الامور تجعل من الصعوبه ايضا الذهاب
للولايات فلا بد من وضع بديل هنا في ولايه
الخرطوم طيب سالم نحن سنعود اليك في سياق
هذه النشره ونشاط المقبل ايضا في سياق في
حال وجود اي تطورات جديده شكرا لك سلم
الهاشمي
[موسيقى]
في لقاء مع العربيه اعرب كريستيانو
الاتحاد الاوروبي في القاهره عن قلقه من
الحرب في السودان قائلا ان هذا دائما ما
يعطي الفرصه للمتطرفين فكريا ومضيفا انه
يرى انه يرى تعامل مصر بحرص على حدودها
حتى لا يكون هناك انتقال للارهابيين اليها
نحن قلقون عندما تدور اشتباكات مثل هذه
وتتحول الى حرب لان هذا يعطي المساحه
دائما لذوي الافكار المتطرفه والارهابيه
اننا نرى ما تفعله مصر الان وهي تتعامل
بحرص على الحدود لتتاكد من عدم تسرب
ارهابيين من خلال حدودها مع السودان
واعتقد اننا سنناقش هذا على المستوى
الثنائي مع نظرائنا المصريين لنرى امكانيه
التعاون في هذا الموضوع
نحن متواجدون في افريقيا ولدينا بعثات
عسكريه وقوه حفظ سلام ومشاركات عسكريه
اخرى مع كثير من الدول الافريقيه وسنرى
كيف يمكن ان نبني على نتائج المؤتمر
بالاتفاق مع كل المشاركين
اعرب الامين العام الامم المتحده
لاخفاق المنظمات في وقف الحرب في السودان
حيث تقوض المعارك المستمره جهود ترسيخ
الهدنه وقال غوتيريش ان الامم المتحده
فوجئت بتفجر العنف في السودان ولم تتوقع
تطور الاحداث بهذه السرعه وشدد غوتيريش
على ضروره التحرك بصفه مستعجله ووقف كل
اشكال التصعيد وايجاد حل يعيد السودان الى
بر الامان والسعي الى تحقيق الاستقرار
والوحده
وفي متابعه الاوضاع الطبيه كشف المتحدث
باسم وزاره الصحه السودانيه دكتور محمد
ابراهيم العربي عن توقف 93 مستشفى على
الخدمه من اصل 143 في مناطق النزاع مؤكدا
ان هناك اكثر من 200 حالتي حاله وفاه جراء
الاشتباكات تم توثيقها حتى الان
عدد الاصابات 3,02 اصابه في القطاعين
العام الخاص الوفيات 207 حاله وفاه في
القطاعين العام والخاص وهذه موثقه اما
بتحويل الى المشرحه وشهادات الوفاء هذه من
واقع السجلات الطبيه
والارغام الاحصائيه بالنسبه لعدد
المستشفيات في ولايه خرطوم يوجد 134
مستشفى عام يتبع للغطاء العام والقطاع
الخاص هذه المستشفيات موزعه على السبع
محليات التي تشكل لها خرطوم
الذي يعمل فيها منها
ثلاثه وتسعين مستشفى بخروج عدد اتنين
مستشفى اليوم
من القاهره مشاهدينا ينضم الينا ننطق باسم
اللجنه التمهيديه لنقابه اطباء السودان
دكتور سيد محمد عبد الله اهلا بك دكتور
سيد معنا في هذه الساعه الاخباريه نتحدث
اذا عن اليوم العشرين من هذه المواجهات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع في السودان كيف
يمكن ان تصف لنا حال الوضع الصحي وفق
متابعتك
الوضع الصحي للاسف شكرا لكم اولا الوضع
الصحي للاسف يعني وضعي كارثي
بعكس ما نسمع من بعض الاخبار
فلولا صمود ولولا بطوله زملائنا وزميلاتنا
في هذه المرافق التي تعمل حتى الان وعددها
فقط الى او يوم او الامس 26 فقط مستشفى
تعمل في مناطق النزاع وحتى هذه تعمل بشكل
جزئي كمثال هناك نداء اليوم في حوالي
الساعه 11:30 على صدر نظام مدير المستشفى
الدولي وهو المستشفى الوحيد في مدينه
الخرطوم بحري الذي يغطي مستشفى الوحيد
الذي بقي هناك صدر نداء منه لان قال انه
بعد ساعه يعني من ذاك الوقت اي في تمام
الساعه 12:30 سينفذ الوقود وحاولوا بكل
السبل لتوفير الوقود فبكل الاثمان لانه
عندهم سينقطع التيار الكهربائي وهذا يهدد
حياه من هم بالعنايه المكثفه ومن هم
تحت التنفس الصناعي
فليخلي مسؤوليته ناشد هذا مثال بسيط عندنا
مثال اخر هو يعني امثله كثيره مثلا في
الجنينه توقفت كل المراغي الصحيه ما عدا
مركز واحد يقدم خدمات بسيطه لما حوله هناك
العشرات الذين لا نعلمهم
توفيوا نسبه لنقلهم من مستشفى الى اخر في
ولايه الجزيره او الولايات المجاوره توفى
الكثير منهم لانه عامل الوقت لانهم في
حاله حرجه وهذا مثال بسيط يعني بفضل
زملائنا بقياده الدكتوره هيبه عمر رئيسه
اللجنه التمهيديه وزملائها الاشياء
والمتطوعين ولجانا المقاومه
يبذلون المستحيل تركوا منازلهم وتركوا
عوائلهم وظلوا لمده اكثر من عشرين يوم
يعملون ليله نهار رغم شحا الامكانيات هناك
نقص في الادويه هناك
12,000 من مرضى الكلى والفشل الكلوي
معرضون
للموت اذا لم تتوفر المعينات هناك مواد
وصلت ولكن لا يمكن نقلها نسبه لعدم نفاذ
الهدنه ونسبه لعدم وجود الممرات الامنه
حتى هذا عند هذه نقطه مهمه جدا يعني
الصليب الاحمر الدولي ايضا كان اعلم قبل
ايام عن وصول مساعدات طبيه الى السودان
عبر ميناء بورسودان هل وصلت اي من هذه
المستعدادات الى مستحقيها
لا حسب علمنا الى الان لم تصل
ونتمنى ان يتم ذلك باسرع وقت حتى نستطيع
ان ننقذ حياه الالاف بلا المئات يعني هناك
نقص في الانسولين هناك نقص في في حتى في
في الضمادات الطبيه هناك نقص في كل شيء
حتى في المياه النقيه نناشر الضمير
العالمي ان تتوقف هذه الحرب عن نستطيع
تقديم ما يمكن تقديمه لانقاذ الحياه البشر
نحن لا نفرق بين انسان واخر نقدم علاجنا
لاي شخص اذا كان مدنيا كان او عسكري طيب
انت اشرت دكتور سيدي الى مستشفى الدولي في
منطقه بحري وذكرت انه ربما يخرج عن خدمه
في حال قطاع التيار الكهربائي الجيش
السوداني اليوم اعلنا ان قوات الدعم
السريعه هل ترك عبر بيان للجيش يعني قال
ان قوه الدعم السريع دخلت مستشفى ام درمان
وحاجه الصافي قال انها استولت على اموال
هناك وان المستشفيات الان في حاله ارسالها
هل بامكانك ان تؤكد لنا صحه هذه الانباء
من عدمها
نحن ندين اي شكل من اشكال التعدي على
المرافق الصحيه من ايا كان
ونعمل لتعمل لتعود هذه المستشفيات انا ليس
لدي اي ولكن كما تعلمون فهناك 17 مستشفى
تم قصفها اخرها مستشفى البراحه هناك سته
عربات اسعاف تم قصفها نحن لسنا طرف في هذه
الحرب ولا يهمنا من هو المتعدي ايا كان
المتعدي فندينه باشد العبارات
ونطلب من الجميع ان يضمنوا سلامه الكوادر
الصحيه وسلامه
المتطوعين حتى يستطيعوا تقديم الخدمه
لشعبنا الحل هو ان تقف هذه الحرب وان تفتح
ممرات امنه وان تقدم ضمانات لوصول هؤلاء
الى الى الى الى هذه المرافق
حتى الوقود لا يستطيع الاصابه كما ذكرت قد
يكون هذا المستشفى الدولي هو توقف تماما
لانه اخلع اخلع مسؤوليته قال ان هناك مريض
سيموت وبكل الاشكال وبكل الاثمان لم
يستطيع الحصول على الوقود عمليه انشاء
انتشار الجثث هي ايضا من المشاكل التي
تؤرق القطاع الطبي في السودان هل هذه
المشكله في طريق هذه الحل الان في الخرطوم
ولا نعمل ذلك لان هناك فرق متخصصه من
الهلال الاحمر ومن الصليب الاحمر
وايضا من الدفاع المدني ولكن يعني حسب ما
نعلم ان هناك جثث يعني متفرقه وحتى فاحه
رائحه هذا بالاضافه الى كل الكوارث
البيئيه المترتبه على ذلك يعني بوجود
القصف حتى الطواقم الطبيه لا تستطيع ان
تصل لانقاذ الجرحى فما بالك بالجثث هناك
معلومات متضاربه حول مستشفى شرق النيل
وهميه المستشفيات المهمه جدا في الخرطوم
يعني الدعم السريع اعلن قبل يومين تعرض
هذا المستشفى للقصف من طيران الجيش هو
مصادر من الجيش ايضا تتحدث عن ما اسمه
احتلال الدعم السريع للمستشفى هل تتواصلون
مع كوادر هناك لتوضيح حقيقه ما يجري
مستشفى شرق النيل تم اخلاعه منذ ايام يعني
ليس هناك اي كادر تبقى به لانه من
المستشفيات التي اخليت قصريا اخليت قصريا
منذ عده ايام
وحتى القصف الذي حدث قبل يوم حدث امام
المستشفى صدر بيان من النقابه بان هناك
قصف امام المستشفى راح ضحيته
العديد من المدنيين لكن لا يوجد هناك لانه
كل الكوادر اخليت من هذا المستشفى ومن
19 مستشفى اخر تم اخلائها تماما لماذا
تستهدف المستشفيات الدكتور سيد يعني في
هذه المواجهات يعني هل لديك تفسير واضح
لهذا
والله لانه يعني المتحاربين هم يريدون قتل
البشر ونحن نريد انقاذ البشر فهذا تناقض
بيننا وبينهم هناك من من يؤجج نيران هذه
الحرب
ولذلك
يرى في النداءاتنا باننا
طرف في هذه الحرب لسنا باي بطرف نحن على
الحياد ونحن مع شعبنا لانقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذ من ارواح لهذا الشعب المغلوب على
امره لذلك قد يرون ان النقابه تعريهم
هؤلاء الذين يقتلون البشر وينشرون الفوضى
ويؤجيون نيران الحرب
ويعملون على على على ان لا يعم السلام
وعلى وعلى
على على على على
اهدار الارواح وحتى
كل القيم التي جبل عليها شعبنا لكن هناك
نقاط مضيئه يعني من هؤلاء المتطوعين
وهؤلاء لجان المقاومه الذين ضحوا بحياتهم
واوصلوا كل المعينات تحت قصف الرصاص نعم
شكرا لك من القاهره بسم اللجنه التمهيديه
لنقابه اطباء السودان الدكتور سيد محمد
عبد الله
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا حذر والي ولايه الشمال او ولايه
شمال دارفور من وقوع كارثه انسانيه
بمخيمات النازحين بعد ان قامت المنظمات
الامميه العامله في المجال الانساني
باجلاء موظفيها بسبب تدهور الوضع الامني
وقال ان الوضع الانساني في الولايه ينذر
بكارثه حقيقيه قبل ان يعرب عن قلق حكومته
تجاه تطورات الحاصله
مقداد حسن اهلا بك مقداد وهل حمل هذا
اليوم اي جديد على مستوى تطورات الميدانيه
والاوضاع الانسانيه
اهلا احمد نعم نحن الان في صدد هذه
التطورات الانسانيه والتي يعني راح ضحيتها
احضاء الضحايا اليوم اثراء القذيفه التي
سقطت في حي الشرفيه بالبارحه وكذلك راح
ضحيتها طفله بعمر العاشره سنوات وراحه
ضحيتها اليوم متاثرا بجراحه محمد حسن ونحن
الان بغضب بصدد يعني تغطيه هذه التداعيات
الانسانيه اثراء سقوط هذه القذيفه على حي
الشرفيه هنا بحي ام درمان وسط ام درمان
ويمكن ان تنتقل الكاميرا يعني ترينا بعض
الشظايا التي وقعت هنا ومعنا ايضا عمران
وهو احد
يعني اقارب الضحايا هنا يمكن ان يحكي لنا
ايضا القصه كامله عمران يعني اين ومتى وما
هي الاثار التي ترتبت على سقوط هذه
القذيفه هنا في حي الشرفيه
السلام عليكم
شايفين اسعار القذيفه
الحيطه والمنزل جوه
والجيران وعندنا جوه في المنزل اثنين
وولد الولد عمره 26 سنه والبنيه
امور 11 سنه
والبنايه امبارح والواد
شايفين الحمد لله ربنا يجيب العواقب سليمه
وربنا يحفظ الجميع والحرب ده ان شاء الله
يا رب يا اخي ينتهي في اقرب فرصه ونتمنى
من برهان يا اخي يقعدوا في طاوله ويتفقوا
لحل الوسط والشعب السوداني زي ما شايفين
الناس شنو في الشارع لانه والله الحال
يعني امبارح جينا الوفا ده الشارع في نهي
وفي حاجات ما قدرنا نقعدوا
عمر 25 سنه حس برضو في في في في في
نواشنه وربنا يجيب العواقف سليمه يا رب
طيب يا عمران نحنا عرفنا منك انك انت شغال
في المنطقه الصناعيه ممكن تحكي لنا يعني
الظروف بتاعه العمال في المنطقه الصناعيه
ام درمان حاليا والله الظروف بتاعه
المنطقه انا شغال في السوق الشعبي
المنطقه ما في فاضحه يعني
حتى لو جوز عاطف بيجيك زول بيكون مضطر
يعني حاجه
جينا فتحنا لحد الساعه 12 الظهر بنقفل
الاوضاع الامنيه عموما كيف في منطقه
والله الاوضاع الامنيه كويسه لكن السوى
الشعبي جوه يعني ما بتلقى زول ماشي بيدينا
العشره اي مواطن شايل له
شكرا عمران على هذه التوضيحات نعم احمد
كما رايت ان الوضع الانساني في مدينه ام
درمان على مختلف المستويات على مختلف
الاماكن ان هذه القذائف وكذلك الوضع على
الارض على المستوى يعني
الذين يعملون في المناطق الصناعيه والسوق
الشعبي وعمال المصانع ايضا يعانون جراء
هذه
الاشتباكات التي يعني
وصلت يومها العشرين ونحن كما كما يعني
عرضت لك الحادث اذا بالامكان ان تنتقل
الكاميرا الى الى الى مكان الشظايا التي
ادت الى سقوط اكثر من يعني سبعه جرحى وفاه
اثنتين احدهما طفله بعمر العشر سنوات
والاخر توفي اليوم متاثرا بجراحه بعمر
السادس والعشرين يمكن ان ننتقل بالكاميرا
لكي يرى المشاهد اذا اذا كان بالامكان
هنالك وقت الان ان ان نرى الشظايا التي
ادت الى سقوط هذه الضحايا وهؤلاء
الجرحى وكذلك ادت ايضا الى انقطاع السلك
الضغط العالي للكهرباء والذي بمجهود شعبي
من المهندسين هنا في غرفه طوارئ يعني تم
ارجاع هذا الامداد الكهربائي هنالك كثير
من الشظايا وكثير من
يعني
المقذوفات التي كانت تترامى هنا في
المنطقه ادت الى سقوط سبعه جرحى وكذلك
وفاه اثنين وتاثر بيتين متجاورين
احداهما على على هنا على ميمنتي هنا
بالباب الابيض ايضا به احدى
الذين سقطوا بالامس نعم احمد هذه هي احدى
تداعيات الانسانيه في مدينه ام درمان وهذا
ما يمكن ان نعكسه لكما استطعنا ان نعكسه
لك في ظل هذه الظروف الامنيه
بالحركه الصوره واضحه شكرا لك وشكرا لضيفك
الذي كان مع قبل قليل
تطورات الاوضاع في بقيه المناطق في
السودان كنت معنا الصحفي مقداد حسن شكرا
جزيلا لك
اما في اخر التطورات عمليات الاجلال
مشاهدينا واصلتنا نيجيريا اجلاء المئات من
رعاياها الفارينه من القتال في السودان
واعادتهم الى بلادهم بعد ايام من التاخير
الذي ترك العديد منهم عالقين كانت مفوضيه
النيجيريين في الشتاهه قد اوضحت في وقت
سابق ان حوالي 2000 هجريه تقطعت بهم السبل
منذ بدء الاشتباكات في السودان
لقد راينا الرصاصه يمر من امامنا واضطرنا
الى الاستلقاء على الارض لا يمكنك حتى
الجلوس لان سماع الضجيج سيء للغايه
وتستطيع ان تراه بام عينك لم اختبر مثل
هذا الوضع من قبل ففي شهر رمضان ونحن
صائمون لا يوجد طعام ولا ماء واصوات
الرصاص في كل مكان
واحده من سلاح الجو النيجيري لكن التقدير
الكلي على متن الرحله هو حوالي 350 شخصا
وفي سياق مشاهدينا قال المتحدث باسم
الخارجي الاثيوبي انه تم تسهيل عبور ما لا
يقل عن اربعه الاف شخص من جنسيه مختلفه
عبر المنافذ الحدوديه مع السودان بالاضافه
لاستقبال اكثر من الف لاجئ سوداني
حتى الان تم تسهيل عبور اكثر من 4000 شخص
من 61 دوله عبر المنافذ الحدوديه مع
السودان وتم السماح ل 75 رحله جويه لعبور
الاجواء الاثيوبيه لاجلاء رعاياها من
السودان انطلاقا من مسؤولياتنا ما يحدث في
السودان سيكون له تاثير سلبي على اثيوبيا
الوضع الحالي في السودان ستكون له تاثيرات
سلبيه علينا نتابع الوضع السوداني بقلق
بالغ ونؤكد تاييدنا دور الامم المتحده
والاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه ايجاد في
الوساطه بين اطراف الصراع السوداني ونؤمن
بان الحوار هو الحل الوحيد للازمه
في بورسودان تسببت المواجهه المسلحه بين
الجيش والدعم السريع في توقف حركه الاف من
شاحنات نقل البضائع من الميناء الرئيسي في
بورسودان الى مختلف الولايات السودانيه
فيما يتخوف اصحاب الشاحنات التي تحمل
الامدادات من القمح والوقود والمواد
الاساسيه من اطاله امل الصراع
المواجهات المسلحه القت بظلال سلبيه على
قطاعات حيويه ومهمه في البلاد هنا في شرق
السودان تبرز معاناه سائق الشاحنات
المتوقفين عن العمل كواحده من تداعيات
الاوضاع الامنيه في السودان
والله المشكله انه العربات دي شاحنه وطبعا
ما قادرين نتحركوا يعني عندنا عربات امس
طلعت
اول نقطه بدات عبور ونرجعها على اساس
البلد ما في امان
دي اكبر مشكله بينعاني منها يعني هسه نحن
عندنا ناس قاعدين من نص رمضان لغايه الان
ما قادرين تتحرك هو عربات شحن وقاعده بس
زي ما شايفين الحديد اهو شاحن واقف والله
شاحنين
سكر شاحنين دقيق
الخرطوم وواحدين ماشيين
بولايه البحر الاحمر بم بها وتتحدث عن
خسائر باهظه كمرحين اصحاب شاحنات
او زياده يعني هذا من جانب اما بقيه
الملفات الخدميه والتنمويه فان السلطات في
ولايه البحر الاحمر تؤكد العمل على
استقرار الاوضاع والتعاطي بايجابيه مع
قضيه اجلاء رعايه دول الاجنبيه الوضع
الامني بصفه عام ممتاز جدا وهادي على
مستوى العشر محليات
الامن في هذه الولايه يمكن الحياه تصير
بصوره طبيعيه كما شاهدتموها ايضا الاسواق
النشاط التجاري بصوره ممتازه بصوره طبيعيه
ما شاء الله ما عندنا مشاكل اياميه
يمكن بالاخوه
العالقين حتى ما غادروا السودان نحن عن
طريق التنسيق مع منظمات المجتمع المدني
والاخوه الخيرين في مدينه
تم اعداد ما يقارب سبعه مناطق قوى بورسان
تقدم فيها كل الخدمات مما شربها وجبات
يمكن تقدم من هؤل الاخوه
البرنامج بصوره ممتازه جدا نزار البداوي
لقناتي العربيه والحدث من مدينه بورسودان
شرقي السودان
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات